good morning john so as you know i run a
youtube company that makes educational
videos and then gives them away it's not
a super great business model but it does
work
most times the company continues to
slowly grow making more things doing
more stuff we have around 50 employees
now you might find yourself asking how
does that work
and that's a great question i imagine
complexly to be a project of
nerdfighteria this is very much where
complexly started and so if you are
curious i would like to share how we
make ends meet in this very new weird
world first youtubers make 55 of the
money that is made by the ads running on
our content youtube also shares 55 of
the money they make from youtube premium
after their record labels take their cut
which if you are curious turns out to be
significantly more than an ad supported
view but most people aren't signed up
for premium so that's around three
percent of complexity's revenue while
youtube ads are around 28 number two
grants a lot of people recognize that
our content specifically crash course
just generates a whole lot more value
than it could ever capture like maybe
millions of times more value and some of
those people are wealthy or they work
for wealthy people or institutions they
want people to have access to great
resources and so they give us money to
make them now grants do sometimes have
strings attached some are extra stringy
but we always make it very clear that
they can give us input and give us ideas
but we are in charge of what gets
created now this can fluctuate a ton
from year to year but last year grants
were responsible for about the same
amount of revenue as youtube was at 29
coming in at just under 20
is crowdfunding so because people know
that basically everything that we do is
not sustainable given the current
business models of internet content they
give us money either through our
patreons or through the crash course i
think everybody supports things for
different reasons but i think there's
like a mix of like a selfish thing where
like i want this content to exist so i
will pay for it and more of a selfless
thing which is that like i will pay for
this so that all people can have access
to it now crowdfunding does not come
with any strings at all where
advertising or grants could so not only
does it make our stuff possible i think
it makes it better because we get to
make all the choices fourth at fourteen
percent of our revenue we also sell our
own ads so like policy genius on dear
hank and john or curiosity stream on
scishow that comes out of our internal
sales team it's more of a pain in the
butt but the ad rates are higher and we
don't have to split it with anybody
number five we also license our content
to various platforms like it's all
available for free but some people want
our content like curiosity stream has a
lot of crash course on it and we get
paid for that altogether all of the
licensing last year was about five
percent of the company's revenue and
last at two percent which is not nothing
but it is two percent is physical
product just bringing high quality
things that provide value into people's
lives like the micro cosmos microscope
which i'm looking at but you can't see
and we'd like to do more stuff like that
which is why get this we are selling
five calendars for five of our shows the
eons and bizarre beasts calendars
features the best of the original art
created for those shows the micro cosmos
calendar features the microphotography
of james weiss our master of microscopes
and the scishow and scishow space
calendars just showcase the variety and
beauty of our world and of worlds in our
solar system every calendar is printed
on high quality people in the us they
ship everywhere and they feature not
just beautiful images but also lots of
interesting facts about those images
because we cannot stop ourselves from
sharing how cool the world is every show
it complexly has a really different mix
of how it makes itself sustainable some
of our shows don't break even for a
pretty long time some of them never do
and we end up canceling them and it's
hard and it's weird and it often feels
like we don't know what we're doing but
there's a reason for that which is that
no one's done this before like companies
like this didn't exist
10 years ago when complexity started
we're just very busy trying things out
seeing what works just using the talents
and skills of people on the team to make
things that are great and that we think
people will like so how about this i
come back next year and i tell you
whether or not that two percent changed
because maybe you needed a calendar and
we made some great ones and they are
available at complexitycalendars.com
john i'll see you on tuesday